before the pandemic San Francisco's
downtown was one of the most dynamic
commercial districts in the country home
to some of the nation's biggest
retailers but today many of those
businesses have abandoned the city these
closures Follow The Disappearance or
scaling back of many of the city's most
prominent corporate tenants like
Facebook and Salesforce downtown San
Francisco today is really a shell of its
former self the way I see San Francisco
from afar is it's amazing but once you
get into the Nitty Gritty like like
downtown and get to the heart of it it's
just it loses its glamour that it has
you know but while a national consensus
seems to have formed around downtown San
Francisco's demise some investors and
businesses think the worst is over and
that the city is now primed for a
turnaround San Francisco's always been a
boom and bus town there is a perception
problem some retailers like Ikea are
moving in and San Francisco 's office
Market is also seeing progress for the
first time since the onset of the
pandemic thanks in part to the arrival
of AI companies but are these recent
positive developments really signs that
the worst is over today almost 32% of
San Francisco's office space is vacant
which is more than seven times the rate
before the pandemic hit and the biggest
increase of any major US
city Cyrus Sandi is the managing
director at precidio Bay Ventures a Bay
Area commercial real estate developer
that sees opportunity in the down Market
recently precidio Bay Ventures acquired
the office tower 60 Spear Street in the
city's Financial District for about $41
million or some 62% less than it sold
for in 2014 so we purchased 60 spear as
an opportunistic investment unlevered uh
with a really long-term Horizon
understanding that San Francisco is a
boom and bus town and looking at
historical Market Cycles we've not seen
basis this low in over 10 years with the
amount of vacancy that's in the building
70% today we were able to really
reimagine the entire building 60 Spears
acquisition represents a new positive
trend within San Francisco's downtown
commercial real estate market after a
long stretch when the city's Office
Buildings couldn't attract buyers sales
are slowly materializing the industry
around artificial intelligence could be
a Lifeline for a struggling American
city recently scores of AI companies
have begun leasing space in the city
suggesting that San Francisco's appeal
as a tech Hub hasn't evaporated there's
been a boom in artificial intelligence
in San Francisco and in fact the top 20
companies in the world eight are in San
Francisco with over 80 companies total
of the 223 companies for artificial
intelligence they're here in San
Francisco despite the new AI tenants and
Signs of Life in the commercial real
estate market serious challenges remain
especially concerning Public Safety and
homelessness San Francisco's downtown
before the pandemic was just absolutely
bustling you know I work on California
Street and there were just throngs of
people was like it's like Manhattan is
like the the the City of Gold since the
pandemic many major US cities saw their
office vacancy rates balloon but San
Francisco is the leader nationally
there's really been a perfect storm
which has kind of imploded downtown San
Francisco over the last four years one
is the high housing costs really forced
a lot of workers to work many you know
miles away because San Francisco became
so concentrated with technology uh
technology is the one industry which got
hit harder by uh remote work than than
any other and that's why here in
downtown San Francisco these office
buildings that surami are mostly empty
and then finally there's been the
problem of crime and homelessness with
which has been around for years but it
really fer and got worse during the
pandemic David Lee is a local restaurant
owner who is lived in San Francisco
since 2005 this year Lee decided to
close his two profitable taco
restaurants after multiple robberies and
instances of vandalism so this is my old
shop this is the old
Taria but uh kind of sad to see it all
gated up Lee is one of many business
owners who have become fed up with San
Francisco not just because of the petty
crime but also because of a lack of foot
traffic when I first started my business
I was averaging about $3,000 at lunch
and I'm about $3,000 at dinner time and
I was only open for 6 hours a day a
short period of time but beginning of
this year I was averaging around like
$11,000 $1,500 a day Once Upon a Time
this was like the busiest Street it used
to be thriving but
now there nobody walking to or from
work sad Le is is now planning to move
his business to Las Vegas Nevada or
Austin Texas because I've been in San
Francisco for such a long time and I've
just kind of seen the decline of it that
um I'm just ready to leave downtown San
Francisco is absolutely crucial to the
health of San Francisco it accounts for
75% of uh the city's budget and revenues
most of the jobs are in downtown San
Francisco without these buildings full
the revenu is going to go down so for
the city to be healthy as a whole the
downtown has to come back San Francisco
downtown as we know it is not coming
back and you know what that's okay in
February mayor London breed laid out her
vision for revitalizing San Francisco's
downtown empty Office Buildings have
fueled dire predictions about economic
doom and screaming headlines about the
death of downtown but let's keep some
perspective here
in 1907 downtown was mostly rubble and
Ash that's considerably worse than
today's shift in how people are working
we do need to you know just be realistic
retail is not what it used to be things
have changed breed is working to
streamline the permitting process for
new downtown businesses as well as
creating more flexible zoning to
diversify the uses of downtown
properties so our economic road map to
recovery for San Francisco go includes a
lot of legislative changes to remove the
barriers that make it difficult for us
to convert um a lot of our office space
from office to housing so we think that
it's going to lead to some more housing
options we think it's going to lead to
uh other uses besides office space and
our hope is that we start to reimagine
what downtown can be other than 9 to5
Financial District or even just retail
and we're going to focus hard on making
sure that people understand what we are
as a city not what others say we are
breed also pushed back against what she
said were unfair characterizations in
the National media tonight Jesse Waters
prime time is declaring San Francisco
has hit rock bottom there's concern that
San Francisco could turn into a
so-called zombie city with its downtown
hul it out it's not to say that you know
we don't have our challenge we're a
major city major cities have challenges
with you know crime and and and violence
and other issues so I do think that you
know there's a perception that when you
see these videos or you hear about
what's going on it's like oh my goodness
what's going on in San Francisco and now
what we're finding is someone else has
tried to Define what San Francisco is
and we have to change that narrative the
mayor has talked about um San Francisco
having uh a perception problem where uh
people in other parts of the country
think it's basically ho I I think that's
the reality is not true there I mean
there are uh parts of San Francisco
which are bad in bad shape for sure um
but for the most part you know it's a
beautiful city I'd say if we're not at
the bottom we're very close from our
perspective and with our investment
Horizon we don't need to be perfect and
time the exact bottom though we feel
we're there San Francisco is is growing
um companies are expanding and making
commit commments to the city but it's
not just in the downtown office space
companies want different things now and
so we have to make sure that we are
adjusting to what the demand is in so
many different
arenas